friend Townsend is CBS news senior
national security analyst she was
homeland security and counterterrorism
advisor for president george w bush and
joins us at the table let's unpack this
friend because the executive order now
keeps families together but a zero
tolerance policy is still in place
that's right so the executive order as
John pointed out in the lead only keeps
them together for twenty days because by
federal by a court order that you can't
hold the children beyond 20 days and so
we've really kicked the can down the
road and put I think from the White
House's perspective more pressure on
Congress you don't solve this in 20 days
we're gonna be right back where we
started and so I do think that it's it
it's not gonna this hasn't solved it but
you're you're a prosecutor would you
prosecute all of these cases I listen
it's clear they're breaking the law but
should it be taken into account while
you're there breaking the law does that
matter at all so you know Gail mostly
the zero tolerance policy is the
deterrent put aside the family
separation because before prior
administrations did not prosecute all
these cases look I was a prosecutor for
many years and you have prosecutorial
discretion to allow the prosecutor to
say that it would be an injustice if we
really prosecuted to the full extent of
the law
and these are misdemeanors the US
Attorney's along the southwest border
don't typically take misdemeanors any of
those kind of resources
there are almost 11,000 children in
custody according to the government what
happens to them now will they be
reunited with their parents so we should
say the majority of the those 11,000
came across alone unaccompanied minors
mostly by what they call coyotes right
smugglers about 2,300 or the result of
the Trump zero-tolerance policy admitted
and it's not clear you know as HHS is
given conflicting statements they do
track these children but what we don't
know is what is the process for
reunification what efforts are made to
ensure that there is consistent and
persistent contact between the child and
the parent who's in custody facing
prosecution none of those questions have
been answered Fran it doesn't look like
Congress in an election year is gonna do
anything exciting so there may be no
action in Congress the judge may not
change anything so this 20 days happens
then what happened
next is there anything other than
keeping the families detained or
splitting them up is there a third
option here your your only options at
the end of the twenty days right is
either you choose to have the
zero-tolerance policy in which case
we're right back again you're gonna
separate these families the children are
going to go the and the parents are
going into Department of Justice custody
to face prosecution or you they agreed
it to immediate deportation in which
case everybody would be sent back but
the president is not going to change I
don't think we ought to think he's going
to change his policy you're either going
to prosecute them and separate them or
you're not and then you're a return to
the idea of what the president calls
catch and release you you can't you
either release them into the United
States with the president Trump is not
going to do or you have them agree to
immediate deportation
it sounds like fran you'll be back yes
Fran Townsend thank you so much